هل سمعت بدراسه الجديده والتي اشارت الى
ان طريقه المشي قد تتنبا باحتماليه موت
الشخص خلال سنوات الخمس المقبله كلنا يعلم
ان المشي والرياضه بشكل عام تطيل من عمر
الانسان وتزيد من رشاقته وصحته الجسديه
والنفسيه ولكن هل فعلا طريقه المشي الذين
نتبعها قادره على اعطاء اشارات دقيقه عن
موعد وفاه شخص هذه الدراسه اجريت في جامعه
الينوي بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واشارت في نتائجها النهائيه انها قادره
على تحديد ما اذا كان شخص قد يواجه خطر
الموت في السنوات الخمس المقبله من خلال
تحليل دقيق لطريقه المشي وسرعه الخطوات
وتسارعها او تباطها والطريقه التي يمشي
بها الشخص اعتمدت الدراسه الجديده بشكل
اساسي على انتشار الموبايلات او الساعات
الذكيه والتي اصبح استخدامها شائعه جدا
والتي تستطيع قياس جمله من التغييرات التي
تطرا علينا اثناء المشيء فتحسب معدلات
التسارع تعد الخطوات سرعه هذه الخطوات او
تباطؤها وتحسب نبضات القلب ونسبه الاكسجين
وبعد قيام هذه الدراسه بجمع بيانات اكثر
من 100,000 شخص استطاع القائمون عليها
تطوير خوارزميه قادره على تحديد مخاطر
الوفاه من خلال تحليلا لست دقائق من
معلومات المشي الخاصه بالشخص الدراسه هذه
قد تحتاج وقت اطول وتحليل اعمق للتاكد من
مدى دقه نتائجها الا انها وغيرها من
الدراسات المرتبطه بالمشي اكد ان المهم
ليس عدد الخطوات التي تمشيها ولا الوقت
انما تسارع هذه الخطوات اي سرعتنا اثناء
المشي فالمشي البطيء لن يساعد كثير على
كسب لفوائد الصحيه الكامله كما ان هناك
اخطاء شائعه خلال المشي يجب الانتباه لها
كالحذاء غير المناسب فالحذاء يجب ان يكون
خفيفا ومخصصا للمشي او الجري المشي بوضعيه
مترهله من المهم جدا الانتباه الى وضعيه
سيرنا فالراس يجب ان يكون للاعلى ونظروك
للامام وليس للارض يجب ارخاء عضلات العنق
والكتفين وشد عضلات البطن اثناء السير عدم
تحديد مده زمنيه والالتزام بها من الاخطاء
الشائعه ايضا فعل الاغلب ستختصر من الوقت
الذي تقضيه في المشي ولن تستطيع الحصول
على الفوائد المرجوه الهدف من المشي هي
زياده تدفق الدم الى اعضاء الجسم مما يؤمن
المزيد من الاكسجين لها اما السير لوقت
قصير لن يساعدك على تحقيق هذا الهدف
الملابس الضيقه ستسبب لك الكثيره من
المشاكل والشعور بعدم الراحه لذلك عليك ان
ترتدي ملابس اطفال وقادره على امتصاص
العرق وجعلك مرتاحه
المشروبات الخاطئه كثيرا ما يعتمد الاشخاص
على مشروبات مليئه بالسكر او الكافيين وهي
غير مناسبه لرياضه المشي ويجب الابتعاد
عنها افضل المشروبات لهذه الرياضه هو
الماء مع تمنياتي لكم جميعا بالصحه
والسلامه والعمر الطويل
[موسيقى]